تقوم سيفين
بفحص ضغط الدم بشكل
روتيني منتظم منذ أن تم
حقنها بجرعتين من لقاح covid19
مرة أخرى في أغسطس في الأصل من الهند ،
وتعيش نفسين في الإمارات العربية
المتحدة وهي واحدة من 31000 متطوع
من أكثر من 120 جنسية
يشاركون في المرحلة 3 من تجارب
لقاح يتم تطويره من قبل
شركة الأدوية الصينية المملوكة للدولة
Cinepharm ،
رأيت والدي يعمل كعامل في الخطوط الأمامية وقد
حفزني للتو على
مساعدتهم بأي طريقة كان بإمكاني
رؤيته وزملائه يعملون
بلا توقف وبلا هوادة تجاه
ما  إنهم يفعلون ذلك هنا وأعتقد
أنه إذا كان بإمكاني أن أكون مجرد جزء صغير
مما يفعلونه ، فسوف يساعد ذلك
البشرية بطريقة ما
36.6 لا توجد حمى ، سيدتي
ميهايلا رومانية وتعيش في
الإمارات منذ 17
عامًا  تقول إنها قررت المشاركة
بعد أن فقدت وظيفتها في مجال الطيران
أثناء الوباء لم أكن خائفًا
بعد أن
نظرت في الآثار الجانبية المحتملة ،
أعرف أن المرحلتين الأوليين من التجربة
كانتا ناجحتين
وفكر في  قررت أنه
يمكنني المضي قدمًا وإجراء
تجربة اللقاح للمرحلة الثالثة ،
لقد تأكدت تمامًا من أن هذا اللقاح آمن حقًا ،
الدكتور جمال الخبيب في المرحلة الثانوية
في وزارة الصحة
في أبو ظبي ، لقد كان من الأوائل  للتطوع
مرة أخرى عندما بدأت التجربة في محاولة
يقول إنه
لتشجيع الآخرين من منظور طبي ، فإن
وجود مثل هذا المزيج الرائع من السكان
والتركيبة السكانية
هو حقًا مطلب حاسم
لضمان قوة البحث
والنتيجة
نفسها ، يشرح أن هذه دراسة مزدوجة
التعمية  اختبار سلالتين من اللقاح
والمتطوعين الذين يتلقون العلاج الوهمي تلقوا لقطتين
متباعدتين لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع ، وكيف سيبدو النجاح
مثل دكتور سائق سيارة أجرة إذا طورنا
مناعة
لأولئك الذين هم في التجارب
ونحن نتحدث عن زيادة مناعتهم بمقدار أربعة أضعاف
ثم في  في نفس الوقت إذا
تعرضوا للفيروس ،
فهل سيحميهم هذا اللقاح أم لا ،
هذا هو سؤال المليون
دولار من حيث السلامة كما
يقول
حتى الآن جيد جدًا.  يقول إن
النتائج الأولية لم تظهر
أي آثار جانبية كبيرة ، والسؤال هو ما
مدى فعالية هذا
اللقاح وهذا بالطبع هو سؤال المليون دولار
والحصول على إجابة لا يمكن أن يكون أكثر
أهمية للسلطات
هنا ، الإمارات العربية المتحدة لديها واحدة من أعلى
معدلات اختبار نصيب الفرد
في العالم ، لكن من الواضح أن كوفيد 19
لن يُهزم
حتى يكون هناك لقاح وعلى الرغم من وجود
قناع
في الأماكن العامة في أبو ظبي
وإرشادات الحجر الصحي الصارمة للأشخاص الذين
يسافرون إلى هنا ،
فإن انتشار الوباء في جميع أنحاء
العالم لم يسلم  هذا البلد الصغير
الذي يقل عدد
سكانه عن 10 ملايين ، شهد ارتفاعًا في الحالات الجديدة
في الشهرين الماضيين بينما لا
تزال النتائج معلقة لمرحلة 3 من التجارب
مؤخرًا منحت القيادة الإماراتية
موافقة طارئة لاستخدامها
منذ ذلك الحين أخبرني الدكتور الكابي أن
اللقاح قد تم  أخذها حوالي
27000 شخص عندما
تعتقد حقًا أن اللقاح
سيكون متاحًا
للتوزيع على نطاق واسع هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وأماكن أخرى على ما
أعتقد  في نهاية هذا العام ،
لدينا إجابة لهذا
النوع من اللقاح الذي نستخدمه من
سينوفارم لإخبارنا بالضبط ما إذا كان هذا
هو اللقاح أم لا ،
أتوقع أن نطور العام المقبل
الكثير
من اللقاح نتحدث عن 75
مليون
جرعات تصل إلى 100 مليون جرعة حتى ذلك الحين
للمتطوعين ، الأمر كله يتعلق
بتجنب
الرضا عن النفس ، ولا أعتقد أنه من الآمن
خفض وقائي حتى الآن أو عدم
ارتداء القناع أو
عدم تعقيم يدي ، لذلك ما زلت
أعقم يدي ما زلت أرتدي
قناع
لأننا جميعًا نمر بهذا
معًا بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن
أبو ظبي